hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to minecraft we are
we are back at it again it has been
quite a while but i have not forgotten
about this and there are some things
about this game that i need to
actually look up and try to understand
because if i keep going at it in
ignorance i will get absolutely
somewhere
but not where i need to be fast enough i
need to get there quicker uh and also i
need to start to understand how this
brewing process works and how like
this weird thing that i have here the
smithing table works
and also i can make an anvil an anvil
will let me repair my items so now i
know why you were so mad
when i threw away my diamond pickaxe
because i was this whole time i was like
what am i doing with all of this
freaking
iron like i got so much of it why do i
need so much of it and yet
here i was being a big dumb dumb well i
could have just repaired it the whole
time
uh well you live and learn you know you
live and learn i guess i'll put this up
here
yeah oh so what this can do
is it can help me to repair things that
are damaged but before i do any of that
i am gonna need more diamonds
until i hit two piles of diamond i'm not
gonna stop
digging that's just how this needs to be
because this game you know
there's a lot to do in it but you know i
got to be patient at some time what do i
do with the blaze run
i spent a lot of effort to get the blaze
rod why did i do that
i should probably remember that either
way i gotta go digging down into the
dirt i need more
food which might mean i need to cold no
i got food okay you live another day
there buddies hi bud what are you doing
with that eating
you eating buddy oh he's in love with me
hey
ow yeah yeah oh yeah okay enough of that
uh we gotta go get to digging
so uh cue the time lapse right about now
where did i go before
what what oh baby
[Applause]
[Music]
what what
three okay
okay oh this thing has fortune in it so
i'm gonna get more
that's good very good okay all right
guys
just bear with me it has been a while
and i'm still not very brain
okay i'm uh just arrow it's just goodbye
hello what do we have here
oh it's a place i've been oh good
great good great
oh it's it's my i forgot i've built this
right and somehow i managed to build
this exactly to the depth that i needed
to build it did i ever explore this
i definitely did did i though
but did i i'm gonna say that i did not
two thousand years later oh my god
it's been so long and i finally found
diamond
oh my god i had three before this oh
my god yes yes
okay how many do i have please tell me
it's good
18 baby 18. my goodness
that took me like 30 minutes to find
that but i got it okay
so i'm going back up i've got 18 diamond
and what this means is that i can use
that to either repair
make more stuff because there's an
enchant for a sword
called looting okay looting much like
fortune gives you more drops from the
people that you loot from like blaze
rods and ender portals
so if i can have that then i would it's
night time
if i have that then hey that means that
i can make what i need to make
it's as simple as that spider what are
you doing alive
oh enderman why are there so many of you
come here you biz nooch
[Music]
hello it can't for me
of course please help sweet
ender pearl okay so if i can make
another diamond sweared
then i need stick also where's my stick
where's my wood
[Music]
if i get stick i'm out of wood is it
gonna find my wood okay it's fine
why don't i have any sort of
organizational system in this why is it
just chaos why does my life have to be
absolute chaos
[Music]
this is definitely not the right wood
but it's a repair it's fine
oh my glass
[Music]
it's fine you know why because i'm tough
and it's not the end of the world it's
just
things things can be replaced number one
i need to make more chess just because
oh the ladders aren't there i need to
make more chill oh my gosh
all right we're gonna cinder this is
so dangerous why do i have that there
why do i have any of this
why did i not think any of this through
why didn't i plan
anything why did i approach this as if
it was just going to be chaos the entire
time
it could have been nice oh all right you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna turn
lemons into lemonade lemon's gonna let
that why does that not sound right i'm
gonna turn the lemons into lemonade
and i'm gonna just make something here
that's gonna help it's gonna be made a
stone at first
put this away for now get some stone in
there it's gonna be a vault
right it's gonna be my vault this is
where all my stuff goes and i'm gonna
have signs on it i'm gonna it's gonna be
nicely organized and everyone's gonna
it's gonna hit the
it's gonna be oh it's gonna be so
satisfying because it's gonna be so
nicely did oh hi
horsey whatever for now this will do
okay this is the entrance to the vault
the vault wall will go all the way over
to there
i wish the ball was a little bit taller
okay
vault vault vault okay so you are all
the weird stuff i got from the end
i mean the nether you're creepy crawlies
like rotten flesh is also qualified as a
creepy crawly run flash ink sack
definitely spider eye creepy crawlies
definitely creepy crawlies okay creepy
crawlies you're
just cobblestone literally
just cobblestone and the rest of this
i'm gonna sort out in time
but that time is not now now that the
crisis have been moderately averted
i'm gonna figure out how to make this
work so run hold on hold on don't worry
about it you're worrying i don't want
you to worry about it
didn't i have another door i do door
that's not quite right god i can't put a
door on right
oh my god don't worry guys
it's all good all good uh
oh no no how do i dig out a door
granite this is the one this is what i
wanted yep there we go
okay so what i wanted to do is i wanted
to try to make another diamond sword
number one
because i'm gonna enchant it i don't
think you can mix and match
different brands of swords i don't have
any lapis one second
oh okay so i put a sword in there and
then i put this in there
boink uh knock back well that's not
exactly what i was hoping for
what if i put that there is it just the
same knockback is that all it is
that's just what it is right now i
really still don't understand the basic
concepts of
enchantment but it's whatever
what who what what what
what what
hello hello
huh hello hello
hello
nope gonna sleep that one away and
pretend like that never happened
nothing ever happened
[Music]
what you admiring my tower sir
okay okay um i'm gonna figure out
so the anvil situation first and
foremost i want to see if it's just
is it just you put this here and then
you put diamond there
and then you repair it and it costs
channel it costs three
how many diamond does it cost salmon
cost one
what does that even mean oh it ah
and you can rename it so what happens
when you combine it with say
this nothing okay well this it repairs
it
fascinating so let me uh go ahead and
i'm gonna put this there i'm gonna get
this knock back
three boom bane of arthropods four
that's also
cool but if i take this and then i go to
the anvil and then i go
sharpness plus this sharpness and
knockback jimmy cause seven
holy crap but i lose bane of arthropods
that's okay
i'm experimenting here ooh ooh
seven but this is how you get the good
stuff right i'm not crazy this is how
you get the good stuff
oh my god all my armor is almost gone
why did i bother with diamond armor
anyway what a waste of diamonds you know
what i mean i could have just made a
nice suit of iron armor and that would
have been just as good right
can you stop hawking loogies over there
pants perfect well now i don't have
enough level to level all these up but
whatever well what would i get them
anyway
oh i ca the whole point of the anvil
maybe i can repair
oh my god why didn't i even think of
that i mean of course i could right
right right isn't that the point man
that was a dumb idea of that
man i'm just surrounded by dumb ideas
you totally can oh my god that would be
so much better than just
trying to build it from scratch oh my
god
oh my god oh my god of course
god of course it is of course it's
better
oh my god of course it is
of course it is of course why are you
there are you stuck
all right i guess you're stuck there
okay so this is good these revelations
are very
good to know i think it's about time to
call the herd
oh my god i have bread i have wheat
i i shouldn't be in the middle of this
when all this loving is going on but
uh you know i live life on the edge man
i live life on the edge
boy there's a lot of you guys in here oh
my god i can you imagine the smell
i don't know how you guys are taking
care of all the poop that must be on the
ground here but uh good job
all right i think i got mostly everybody
here oh my god
all the children are in this tiny circle
time to
call their blab blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah
blah i don't know if i'm killing the
babies too but uh
oh it's an accident it's an accident i
swear swampy
oops oh man culinary's hard work
hard hard work man hard work man
tough debt no no you don't want to get
out you'll be next on the list bam
oh well he's free jailbreak blanco
lumpy blumpy wumpy schpumpy
and then u4 will raise the rest i've
gotta go
take care of a thing
all right good job hey way to survive
all right see you around guys hey you
you guys still there good good to know
okay you'll be the random gold that i
get from
whatever land i still don't know about
potions but already making progress so
there's a way to upgrade gear i'm
actually going to look up this one i'm
going to look up the smithing table okay
tool smith's job site block it generates
in villages can be used to upgrade
diamond gear into netherrite gear
ooh interesting despite being crafted
from iron ingots
smithing tables cannot be smelted to
make iron and get smelted
smelted i can smelt things so i need
netherright ingot crafting netherright
scraps and gold ingots together
how do i get netherrite scraps smelted
from ancient debris which is found in
the nether what's ancient debris
ancient debris is like fine diamond but
in the nether you gotta go way down and
then you got
all right man look i'm not here for the
oh it's dark
that's that sounds real tough man that
sounds real tough
i don't know how to do that man okay
don't know about that man main man oh
that's a lot of knock back i remember
why i didn't put anything in any sort of
organizational structure when you get to
the point where you have this
and you're in for you're just like ah
whatever chuck it wherever i don't even
care anymore
and i really don't here goes any chance
at organization i ever had
i say as i organize smartly okay so
to get that you need to have a lot of
stuff in the nether which i could go to
the nether again and i could try to get
netherite ore
you know what let's try ancient debris
either way it means i gotta go down in
the nether
not just likes whoa oh yeah i forgot it
changed my
location for some reason okay so i gotta
go down how do you even know how far
down you need to go
okay i'm actually gonna use this area
over here that i've already
created a nice ladder for him to go down
as opposed to just digging randomly
which would probably lead to my demise
i've never actually tried to mine in the
nether very much anyway
oh never ow
[Music]
when does it put out thank you
it said why negative 15. i i like i i
don't know what that means it's some
kind of
i don't know what language they're
talking about let's just try here
this seems as good as any i'm assuming
that just like the entirety of this
entire world at this point down is just
lava is it just that the base layer of
this is always going to be lava
no no you mean that can just go keep
going down
okay well this is new i didn't think
that there was a further down
apparently there's a further down
oh it just goes how far down does this
go
how far down does it go
oh is that bedrock that's bedrock isn't
it okay that's bedrock okay
so if this is bedrock one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11
12 13 14 15. here
this should be the level this should be
the level that has all the goodies
how uh what what is going on here
some don't feel right about this what's
that okay there's quartz
okay so there is stuff down here i still
don't know what to do with nether quartz
i could look that up too
because there's got to be some kind of a
function to it
oh boy oh boy oh boy boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god that flew
out a lot faster than it
should have
yeah something about lava in the nether
just flows really fast it's a lot more
viscous
okay we're good no we're not good we're
not good god where is it oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh i've screwed it oh i
screwed it
okay got that jeez how far have i gone
this is absurd this is just absurd
oh oh oh oh it's right oh
it's right that's the stuff that's it
that's stuff
oh i got it
is it just the one really all of that
for
just one well let's try to get at least
one more
i guess maybe going in a line ain't the
best idea what if i just like dig
everything out i don't know maybe i
shouldn't go in a line
at this point i don't even know
geez this is messed up man this feels so
wrong
this feels completely unminecrafty i
feel like
it feels like i'm cheating on something
damn look at me go
look at me go uh oh look at me go oh god
look at me go oh god
okay look at me go look at me go look at
me go look at me go
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy uh oink oink
okay uh look at me go
oh god oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay
okay that was a bad idea lava in the
nether is no joke guys
i don't know if you knew that oh boy you
know what just screw it
this is the way judging by the drips of
lava in the ceiling i'm assuming there's
lava up there
yep okay seems like the lava really
wants to be just a little above me so
what if i just start digging down a
little bit
oh i'm out of torches god damn i did not
think that i would be digging through
this much
okay i'm gonna head back up now i guess
one is gonna have to do it i don't know
how much
one is gonna get me i'm gonna imagine
that one is not gonna get me a lot but
if it does
then hey that'd be good but knowing this
game and its ability to make me grind
for things i'm gonna assume that it's
not gonna be very much
hey bud why are you burning it's not
even daylight
looked at me couldn't help it catch on
fire
okay all right i don't want i i don't
want to know what kind of potion that
guy's chugging every morning
hi bam okay so i got one of these do i
put it in the smelter
put you in here yes okay well it's gonna
make some scraps now what i do with the
scraps is another good question
hi yeah boom now the right scrap
not scraps singular scrap oh
but there's a book recipe okay so
i'm guessing that's neth never mind
i need four dang it ding ding
okay i need four which is a lot but
you know i guess that's fair kind of oh
man why do i have so much of this
why do i have so much just put it in the
river just put it in the water hole i'm
just gonna put it i'm just gonna put it
in the water hole how do i
get no not one at a time how do i just
get rid of it just get rid of it just
get rid of it put it in the water hole
still i've got an inventory bomb of
netherrack just right there i don't want
it i don't even want to put it in a
chest
why would anybody want to do that how
about in my vault you're
not netherrack goodies
there here you go gold nuggets scott
gold what the most
useless thing possible torch torch
there we go nether scraps there flint
not
there there flint ah whatever you know
what i'm not even gonna worry about that
right now because i've got another
thing that i need to look up anyway
which is the nether portal
which is the thing that's gonna help no
not the nether portal sorry
end portal what
what is a stronghold strongholds can be
located using an eye of ender
okay all right what if i'm reading this
correctly number one i can't
build an ender portal i have to find
one said and portal how did i make
i of ender again blaze powder
right blaze powder i
have ender so if i use this it's going
to
tell me where a stronghold is where i'm
related
put on the dramatic music
that way
okay good good good good good good
okay at least it didn't use up the eye i
thought it might have been using it but
hey this is good so that means that the
nether portal is
straight over that way right about where
that tree was so
schwoompi you and me we're going on
adventure
oh what no why you blow
no why you blow up why did it blow does
that mean it's near
god damn it but oh but it's oh it's here
anyway i gotta get a boat no
turtles but it's all but no
but this is a bunch of baloney
all right well i guess i got to do the
long ride back home the ride of shame
crossed the several rivers that i almost
drowned upon but whatever
this was a fruitless venture i didn't
know that the eyes could explode
and it i can't even reach it anyway but
whatever it's all good i'm not worried
why should anybody be worried how many
times have you thought you were on the
right track only to be led astray at the
last moment because you didn't fully
understand the mechanics or you didn't
read the
problem in question so you were left
floundering wandering back home very
slowly
and then probably drowning and then your
horse drowns
where'd my horse go standing on water if
you could stand on mars this whole time
why you fall
is it me call me fat so uh yeah how many
times has that happened to you leave a
like if that has happened to you
this is me when i totally screw up what
i'm doing
hey i can see that at the distance god
my dirt nether portal
oh my goodness okay but we're making
progress
we're learning we're learning things
we're learning here's your friends
see you around shwoompi all right
goodbye
we're learning and that's what really
matters i've got more than i'm gonna do
in the next
episode and i'm gonna make a lot more
progress than i have not that i haven't
made a lot of progress i made a lot of
progress in these but
i'm gonna make a lot more progress so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
oh